boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sakyan we
are still on site in Boston
Massachusetts this is now our third
episode featuring core's number one
question asker Alex K Chen what's up man
hey what's up what's up thanks for
coming on to the show yeah yeah for the
third time the second time in Boston we
came on the show in San Francisco last
time no the first yeah it's reverse of
Boston oh yeah because the first time we
were in summer yeah yeah which is in the
Boston area so twice in the Boston area
which has been good and we're having
Alex on for the third time because our
conversations with Alex
they're multi-disciplinary they're super
pushing The Cutting Edge of knowledge
I'm just very very meta Alex is better
yeah that's right you are I like that a
lot and I like how you are again pushing
the cutting edges of knowledge a lot and
that's what we want to talk about in
this episode and I love thinking about
things in terms of like a ring of
Cutting Edge knowledge and that there's
Humanity civilization has evolved to
know certain things this collective
learning and the collective learning's
been pushed to this ring but there's
things in the unknown in the outsides of
the ring and Alex likes to live and I do
too a lot on that outside of that ring
trying to scrape and find more
information so tell us about why you're
so passionate about that
um edgenith I just know that being that
good things are likely to happen to you
more often if you just do edgy scenes
you also are more likely to stay
relevant over time
and if you're if you stay relevant over
time it basically means that people are
people more willing to pay attention to
you or things you touch and and also it
helps you basically adapt to a world
that is constantly changing
yeah staying relevant you can actually
adapt more in a world that's changing if
you stay edgy you're not in the sort of
conformist
area that so many other people fall into
it's nice to stay on the edge yeah
uh okay keep going on on on edginess I
think if you're constantly edgy you're
also more likely to discover facts about
yourself or the world that allows you to
escape
um local Maxima that people somehow have
a tendency to stick to
mm-hmm so it's almost as though there's
a uh constantly pushing the the
boundaries of what is is being discussed
in the conversations that you have is is
actually will get you much further and
it'll get the overall collective
learning that's going on in that Circle
further
yeah hmm yeah okay
so how do you push the edge
um so I will acknowledge that I'm not
I'm I'm not as good as at it as I could
be
um
of course this is true for all other
people I think exposing myself to new
ideas and people from all the time
um especially in different domains
um and also just like figure out the
statement uh the stimuli or people that
help you maximize your learning rate a
period of time since
um there is like a very specific type of
pattern information that basically
optimizes your learning rate or often
with your experiencing rates
and it it has like there's a
relationship between all the knowledge
you have and and whatever knowledge that
optimizes that that rate is and
oftentimes being there uh where
um where you you can't have everything
basically thrown at you it's one which
um to basically you know for example
um oftentimes the fastest when you're
talking to someone the fastest learning
rates uh when talking to someone are
like when you're in crowded
multi-dimensional settings
um or like setting for you to know other
people and then you see and you
basically watch
um it's like there's a lot of
information that's that's basically
covered that that you can basically like
kind of figure out even if you you can
mentally map semantically you
um you you just notes and observe those
over time so basically like
um the more stimulated faster learning
rate hmm okay so optimizing learning
rate for yourself and others I like that
a lot so yeah there's there we've talked
about this before on the show but it's
so sad that we'll never be able to know
everything well let's bring computer
interfaces maybe we'll be tied into
everything uh soon but what does for you
what does it mean then to optimize that
rate of learning specifically for you
you started kind of pointing and uh and
touching at it and it we have the
limitation in just 80 years of time so
we got to figure out what environments
what people yeah should surround
ourselves with what information areas on
the internet should we surround
ourselves with so start talking so I
think areas and I could stay relevant
those are recurring relevance
and
um oftentimes
um
like those that
um the areas so basically I used the
heirs I used to be attracted to are
aren't heiress and most people want to
learn unfortunately because they're not
relevant you know if he was live even
though you can spend entire lifetime
just spending just studying um areas of
psychology that are universally relevant
to people
um though even then most people will not
necessarily learn uh if um most people
are not served best by learning each and
every area of that um oftentimes
um let's say
then how you behave in very unusual
situations for example the type of
learning and then sometimes if you can
remember well enough it gives you the
courage to push through
um other situations who are not feeling
optimal but you know you have the
confidence that pushing through will
basically lead uh good things will
happen if you if you do push push
through so so once you like the
basically learning of that's that kind
of confidence but also
um I'll learn the area of confidence in
areas where you um where you're uh
expectations or feedback loops are in
such a way that you won't over stretch
and burn yourself out
them you you bring up this really
important point you can't really push
the the edge of knowledge of of humanity
without having confidence you have to
have confidence to be able to go and
know that even though 99 of people
aren't thinking the way you're thinking
that you can still be right potentially
and you can go and work either with
other people or even alone and and aim
to push that Cutting Edge have edgy
conversations with people go to edgy
places on the internet now oh The Edge
that's what there is no fight yeah
that's right the edge.org right yeah
yeah yeah that is it's a good there's a
lot of good content there
um
okay and the only way that we've gotten
to where we are today is because humans
decided to push the edge over and over
across all the different disciplines and
growing the collective learning pool
over time yeah so what else do you think
are some of the you know the
characteristics or the motivations
behind people wanting to do that
um I mean sometimes it's just survival
um because there are environments where
you have a large portion of the
population that does get wiped out and
though so for example even gentle
Holocaust and um the people who usually
who got out before everyone got wiped
out for those who constantly thought of
the information about what happened in
the world and they take a step to
prepare to move well before the cities
actually happened
damn
so that's as though uh people can sort
of hedge against upcoming threats
potentially
oh yeah that's kind of what we see a
little bit with the bunkers that were
made during the nuclear cold during the
Cold War throughout yeah also it's not
just that you also want to be
sufficiently valid enough such that
people will want you to basically
survive through the threat because not
um unfortunately it
um not everyone like it's hard to Value
every person equally and in situations
of scarcity or survival when everyone
else is there when everyone else is
thinking about surviving themselves and
in these bottleneck events
um you basically want to figure out how
to maximize your chance of going through
yeah yeah
oh
yeah the uh
the chances of becoming irrelevant as
you said earlier you don't want to
become irrelevant you want to survive
you want to survive and you want to
flourish both okay so in the Modern Age
now with the abundance of information
the abundance of our ability oh yeah oh
yeah it's like attention is also being
followed and more and more attention is
it's like attention is kind of becoming
more zip flawish it's like more
attention is going into fear people
which is why a lot of people are feeling
lost neglected and sad and people often
decry this as some sort of
um so widespread social malaise which in
some respects it probably is
um but on the other hand
um if people are if people are kind of
are insecure and looking only for
themselves then this is something you
might you might see a bit more of and
this is where like skill where the
skills that are important for it um
for staying valued
um include ones like pushing the edge in
ways that other people are a little bit
too afraid of or don't have energy for
or
um somehow don't think even think of as
possibilities
yeah so it's like kind of like an upside
risk kind of scene
yeah
and I want to speak a bit more on the
the abundance of information is both
incredible and it's also can be at times
distractive yeah it can be yeah so talk
to us about that so it's also a matter
of when you're pursuing that information
and if you are
um archiving it in a way that allows for
Ev re-access in the future in a way that
makes you want to re-access it into the
future
so
so the archiving of information so okay
so as you push the the edge of knowledge
and you're you know we'll talk a bit
more about how how you're working with
the people on that how do you archive
information
um like infant brow the history is in a
quarter and basically have a tool to
scrape um all of a sudden you can
browser history I don't do well now if
I'm taking more screenshots on the
computer screen these days and also um
if I think something's gonna be
important for some in the future or for
myself or something I want I want I want
all future people to know I am
definitely screenshot it because
otherwise there's no there's going to be
no way to capture or bookmark it or or
some sort of low stakes way um though I
feel they're still like setting up costs
that sometimes get disrupted when you
switch platforms which has happened to
many people over the years yeah
okay so let's talk about
um Bloom 2 Sigma yeah this is very
interesting so you choose to work on a
one-on-one basis ideally ideally with
people at the edge of their fields and
just or people who are just ridiculously
good at what they're at yeah yeah and
you're we like using this analogy of
playing a game of tennis so you're you
know people that are high openness you
can basically hit them over an
interesting idea tennis ball and they
can hit it back over to you with some
added thoughts and you can keep pushing
the boundaries of the circle of what is
the edge of knowledge yeah yeah another
high openness may not be being a pretty
attention existing thoughts and also I
was being attentive to adjusting their
frame frame in a way that
um basically makes uh basically it makes
that thought optimal or think about
better better ways to
um uh make uh applies optimally apply
the knowledge
okay I like how you talked about
adjusting the frame and being humble
about like basically augmenting your
perspective adding to the lens of which
you see the world because somebody can
always hit you with something that is
like oh that shatters the way that I saw
things before yeah yeah just not being
attached to your to your general
thoughts at all which means like not
being right of not being obsessive being
right all the time and not not even
putting emotional violence into being
right
um
so what how do you not attach emotional
valence to being right I think having
and think curiosity about the world just
knowing uh having the intense conviction
that
um you need to operate that way in order
to in order for good things to continue
happening to you or or whatever your
experiencing your Consciousness in your
conscious frame basically
um the moment that you attach your
emotions to your ideas and and your ways
of thinking and seeing the world and if
someone comes and tries to tries to
augment your perspective and you're so
attached to it you don't see what
they're saying you're you're you lose
the opportunity to enhance the way that
you see the world yeah there are a lot
of weird social incentives and all that
people hold you being right the first
time or to uh or to say
um being the first right answer or just
having political views that they don't
want to budge from and it's kind of
weird because I'm not sure if it's even
all that
integrated within say their utility
functions at all
um it's actually uh I don't know where
to put it in terms of utility functions
because there's I mean people
in general people in general people do
uh people do respect people more if they
know that they're right in most
fundamental issues
um like hey um if someone tells you I
believe oh if if x if you say something
I I'm really convinced I only think
you're you're right that's kind of
flattering in that way because uh
because it's also like attach this
notion of value and um
intelligence and all that other stuff
for example if you were to to counter my
perspective on world peace I really I
want world peace I believe in world
peace I believe that we can dose up on
love and get to world peace together and
if you're to say it's never going to
happen
right
I stand quite firm on on my on my stance
there I don't I don't want to budge from
that so what you're saying is a value
judgment not a epistemic judgment okay
okay like a political judgment sure sure
um so then if we're talking like um the
the Earth being the third planet from
the star or something like that you know
you can't really budge me from that
that's Justified truth that's
epistemology right
okay
so then you can't budge me from that
right
right is that where mostly yeah mostly
I'm not going to go into the huge debate
okay all right all right
um
yeah there's a lot of different ways to
talk about the way to enhance people's
perspective in ways that kind of make it
so that people don't feel hurt by them
saying that I'm wrong or we are quite
attached to saying I'm right about
things and it actually does cause a lot
of of uh of
slow down in civilizational progress due
to
due to being attached to the thought of
wanting to be right okay so let's talk
about this um Bloom to Sigma so you pick
you pick people that you really think
are open very high openness low negative
emotion yeah and you work with them and
on pushing the boundaries of what you
know and what they know or like you send
them a bunch of emails or questions like
what like what it used to do with quora
and then sometimes they just reframe it
and you know a way that makes it more
understandable to you and in a way that
makes it easier for you to retrieve it
later
uh okay so so you would
you would you would submit your um when
you submit your questions core via email
yeah on YouTube used to
um you would uh have the questions
posted and then you get a people that
would reply to you on quora um reframing
the question in a way that you thought
was potentially better
and also reframing just answering in a
way that um
that basically updates my knowledge of
it sometimes oh that's cool give me a
good example of that do you remember
someone's uh of someone's class of how
someone updated my framing yeah yeah
um I'll have to think about that more I
mean nowadays I just I stick to email
threads
about meditation where someone talked or
someone talked about all my verbal games
being similar to just
um pushing the button the dashboard
without actually doing the scene it
because a lot of times
um people who are heavy readers or
people who um or a lot of even academic
people they they have a tendency to just
try to describe every single ways it
makes it understandable so actually
understanding the process itself
oh okay
so
what would that look like for give us an
example of when someone is just doing
what you just said about not actually
potentially putting your pushing like
for example observing someone playing a
video game and then describing it in the
way of an anthropological sociological
researcher versus actually do actually
playing it yourself and get into the
scene or saying something to say
um programming when you're just you're
just observing programmers rather than
actually programming teams yourself
um or
um
creating huge elaborate social theories
of how people interact without
interacting with the people themselves
so sometimes there there isn't really
any other options other than by going
the data that you have
so what would you then recommend is a
good balanced strike between the playing
around with the different with the
different buttons and also talking about
the buttons
um so I think talking about about the
pleasant can redirect attention to uh
ideally towards people uh towards say
um uh have it playing with the buttons
for people who have skin in the game I
like that I like that point so this is
the more that you potentially talk about
the The Edge let's say of knowledge the
more people will be like why is that
interesting I should maybe talk about
that yeah I mean it'll be interesting
talking to leave about it because he
probably knows a lot of people who are
like you like him a lot edgy um but then
tale of no skin in the game yep yep so
okay so what about what about um what
about your thoughts on people that are
edgy but don't have skin in the game
tell us about that
um well a lot of the philosophers and
academics are kind of like that and they
they just write and write and write and
sometimes not without having exactly
through feedback
there's like an explosion of academic
journals or more problems in their
eyeballs are able to read them or even
any feedback loops that people are
actually say updating favorably to what
uh what they're publishing
um though uh that depends from a field
you feel how the feedback apps Act
and then okay so when you're uh I when
you've identified the um the individuals
that you're working with how many people
are you usually aiming to because I see
as you interact when you're on your
daily you're constantly um task
switching between reading and your
different threads of people that you're
playing this um this game of edge tennis
with how many uh people are you playing
Edge tennis with oh probably like 20
plus a day
um I don't know about day maybe five to
ten plus five to ten a day and 20 in
like a in a week or something yeah yeah
probably interesting
um and then that is you would say one of
the largest contributors to your
intelligence
um hopefully in the long run yes yeah
and then you want to use this sort of
process that you're learning about
engaging with people in this Edge tennis
and you want to help other people see
that as a as a strong way to expand
one's intelligence yeah yeah
okay
and then
what what is it like then for you to
deal with different give me some
examples of like someone that's really
high on openness when you play tennis
with them oh hi an openness someone who
basically tries all possible
Arrangements they don't they don't
um they don't stick to the same patterns
all the time they're willing to
embarrass themselves and look foolish or
suffer local losses in the process of
trying to learn a better route or
themselves even if it might translate
without an accelerated payoffs in the
long run
um they could also um they also
some of them have very good ability they
also like have strong attachment to the
older games so it allows them to discuss
their older games other people and tell
them insights what it's like
um
like they they basically they
fundamentally like value they haven't
trained the value of it on their hits on
the player history
hmm oh I like how you mentioned that
it's cool for them to kind of take an uh
they're not scared to have an experience
where they admit that they're wrong or
that they have uh that they have to give
up some sort of a notion that the way
that they saw the world in order for
them to actually gain more uh-huh but
yeah that's a really important
um okay and then what is it like
potentially for you to to work with
people at other levels do you even do
you even do you work with people that
have low openness at all
[Music]
um
I mean I instruct my parents
I know our older Generations can
sometimes be lower on openness I know
sometimes you can not submit sometimes
you can nudge them a little bit easier
yeah so how old are the people that you
would say are most on the open are you
seeing like 25 year olds is that kind of
um technically high so ties open to
people really are um
our young young kids and teenagers
except Society just somehow decides the
best ideas to insulate them from
everyone else which prevents them from
really relating their true openness and
then they just end up
and those self-contained grades that
aren't exactly good for personal
development but also like safety
obsessiveness that happens over them too
but anyway that's beside the point um in
practice people who are high openness
um it's like yeah usually it's um late
teens to the 20s and some there are some
who stay stay that way even higher up
interesting
and you know we've talked about this a
little bit before and this is kind of
relevant to what you were just saying
about how there's uh there's an over
protection that's going on with kids
there's the you know we're talking to
Whitney about this earlier as well just
the essence of of of of of of
controlling parenting rather than
openness with people yeah yeah and also
it's like this is also something related
to people who wants to think they're
right but to like why didn't you think
do you think they're right from trying
to protect their kids against when
telling the kids for example don't go
into the car bad things will happen to
you it's like that's that's what it
starts and then and then people get
scared and they have vested interest in
defending their fear which is like
defending ones on fear is one of the
biggest impedances Society of progress
as we see also with what happened before
say gay marriage or weed legalization
oh interesting so the the the the
coddling of the Mind ends up oh yeah
okay even like even in today's safety
faces people have best interest in
defending those safety spaces while
actually trying to see the consequence
of what happens if they you expose
people to scenes that don't necessarily
directly hurt them yeah we got to build
up the immune system to adversity
and to challenging with the way that we
see them yeah
the problem is that a lot of a lot of
these things do need to be reframed in
ways that are less direct new people and
most people don't have the verbal
agility to do uh to do clever reframings
this is like like some I saw in the
Science Blog how someone said in order
to give feedback two-day these days you
have to acknowledge the person that's
right in these in its Dimensions before
actually giving them critical feedback
oh my gosh Ah that's such an interesting
point because
um I've made it clear now that I don't
mind however the feedback comes so
I have a mentor that delivers oh yeah
you have two fee the most vision and one
way to prepare with one more way to
prepare yourself for is this is to just
tell yourself that the the person it
could potentially be open to change
their mind about you in the future it's
just a local opinion that's held right
now that can always change
and it is quite possible that if you
listen to someone that's delivering you
feedback in a way that to you may not be
the most pleasing or uncomfortable give
people return chance give people Second
Chances and not only that but also just
like look at them even though they may
be potentially coming coming at you
right giving you that harsher critique
but actually listen to every word they
say because what they are saying is
actually the most important truth that
you need to hear when someone's like
looking at you and they're like you know
you're power hungry or you're like
you're overly greedy in these scenarios
or are you coming from an intent of of
malevolence in that scenario and when
they're challenging you in those ways
and you're and you you're like no I'm
not and you look back away from from
what they're saying you're not even
reflecting you can actually deeply take
what they're saying and reflect on
yourself and say whoa okay maybe I
actually am being a little greedy in
this respect or regarding yeah and you
can grow better so yeah you got to get
used to having feedback delivered in all
kinds of ways yeah yeah no I think in
what way that people are not used to
having feedback delivered is because if
if someone says that hey maybe you
should reframe your goals a lot of
people go when you ask other people's
life goals they often refrain they often
frame their goals in ways that can be
they're frustratable and that may not
still be the most robust and um getting
people to reframe it goes a different
way uh can be a way to
um get the make them more receptive
feedback in the long run but this tends
to there's more likely for people who
are not overly invested in the system
yep and this is I want to mention this
because you know you helped bring this
to light for me the idea of um of Bloom
2 Sigma specifically ends up having a
one-on-one mentor and this is actually
something I mentioned about
um to Ben Buddhism as well just the idea
that the lineage is passed on from a
teacher to a practitioner yeah and I
think that's a very exciting way and
it's now really really proven that
having that sort of a learning style two
puts you two standard deviations above
someone that doesn't have that style of
learning which is huge on the on a scale
of growth
um now now that's why you pick this
style of Engagement with these with
individuals is this one-on-one on your
Edge I'm not sure if exactly what I do
you do a lot of groups as well yeah is
what you do yeah yeah enough I'm not
very intense I'm very distributed rather
than intense yeah yeah you are you are
well you're multi-disciplinary you're
not yeah yeah
but you do have a focus on Aging it's
been something that you're focused on um
yeah yeah also just putting pushing that
edge to
hmm
Okay so
okay let's let's see let's see where um
where some of these some of these
questions get us
I've been I've been I've been investing
a lot of of energy into figuring out how
civilization got to where it has oh God
it's so weird it's
ah yeah go on it is very weird yeah
super strange tell me why you think it's
weird
um
there are so many ways okay
I mean you have the furry Paradox and
all that
um
it's also like
I don't know it's like we also did it
even though even though we have like
such nasty cognitive algorithms we're so
irrational on the massive scale we're
it
it's like
a lot of the people in power are always
like to have throughout history have
been legitimately shitty even but then
there's like technology technology
progress happens anyways and people are
not Mo very very very few people
actually wise people who write history
in fact tend to be a very very
um non-representative sample of everyone
in the world
um
and it's like the level of
self-awareness in people even the
smartest people is like solo even if you
look like the smartest philosophers it's
like there's a lot about life that they
don't typically get that maybe some
Modern people get
those were all so good
okay there's
I remember when he said that
history being written by only a small
amount of people
there's so much
that we didn't actually accurately
keep as a record of how we got yeah and
people because oftentimes um the value
the valuation for computational people
are not exactly rewarded for this they
generally see it as something that
markets not rewarding people yeah for
good things are not likely to happen to
those who are historians of internet or
archivists or um
or just
people Jesus like even guern is not
exactly as reality should be
and that is again the green.net he's
like someone uh he's like very very
methodical in his observations of um
basically like uh emerging Trend in the
top 20 years and he's very open about
himself in a way that most of people are
not open about them like it does take a
very high a degree of openness yeah in
order to be reliable a historian or
narrator
yeah we we're constantly wanting your
perspective to be enhanced by new
information and being open to it yeah
yeah
I find it very weird that
we have yet to fully come to the
realization that we all
evolved on this rock together and we're
still having issues with
greed and War and poverty and we're just
we have so much abundance but we're so
caught up in power controls
that we're we forget about how to figure
out the long term how to slow down oh
yeah yeah power and control those those
stupid power dynamics battles people
play with each other like with parents
and children for example
um where it becomes insufferable to stay
with them because of the the cost of
need the constant need for control or
something or like obedience or
um you highly recommend a path uh of of
around what age of like 18 or so taking
a path of like maybe exploring some
metropolises or going away from your
nest oh the earlier the better but yeah
well you can't really can you go pre-18
look at Target Aurora okay
what time does she leave the nest uh she
left at 16. 16. okay okay yeah yeah we
can we can be down with uh with helping
young people
um uh find places in Metropolis is to go
out and start surrounding themselves
with like scientists and engineers and
artists and different thought leaders
that would be fun entrepreneurs yeah I
like that young people getting out there
um
okay we talked a bit about the weirdness
um how about what what about what
transcends this reality what exists
outside of the 3D reality
um there are many many theories about
this a lot of speculation about it
um I know so many people who are like
obsessed with this question it's like it
becomes their singular obsession
and what are your thoughts
um there are a lot of there are a lot of
like Loop that people a lot thought
Loops are like memes and people
attracted you like people when people
say they see aliens and DMT I'm not
actually sure if I believe it's just a
meme that easily propagates
that somehow people find easy to believe
which actually makes it less believable
now now is there some sort of uh greater
power that made this big bang happen
um
I at this point I don't necessarily have
a good idea to get from this at all okay
and what have been some of the things
that you've been studying at the edge
that you think you wanna share with
people right now that maybe less the
people don't really know too much about
or haven't been studying too much I
think a lot of times people even as
um I think edgy ways of
being super open to the world of like
publishing all raw data rather than just
published it I don't want to go to
African papers
um also ways of also people tell me tell
me that it's not just semantic knowledge
that I should go for it's also like some
sort of experiential knowledge
um like uh oftentimes the type type that
easily
um that even more like one person told
me Alex what I I would be fast if you
see what would happen to you if you just
went for six months in Indonesia in Java
and then just surfed all the third for
that period of time it might change your
internal lived experience so much that
um that in a way that's uh say
affects everything in the future in a
good maybe in a good way if Alex went to
Java for six months yeah and surfed yeah
I
I yeah that breath that you just took I
think that may happen at a little deeper
scale I think you you may have a
potentially a more uh potentially a more
a way of seeing reality potentially a
slower uh
um Earth connecting to Earth yeah and
yeah yeah I know someone else who a good
friend who just went to India for like a
month and stayed away from the standard
Academia influence and social bubble
yeah yeah
and even if you just go for a month yeah
and come back I think it'll be quite an
enriching experience for you it also
depends on what you do oh yeah totally
you just go and hang out internet cafes
on social media it's not what is that
right but um
okay how about
what would you say is a central guiding
principle of your life
um stay relevant
as in staying relevant so you stay
relevant for yourself or for society to
see you as someone that is a beacon at
the edge both uh both are relevant or
like some some someone to pay attention
to or good things that will happen if if
they if you pay a little bit more
attention to X or even give them
resources and see what what x does make
useless resources
interesting I feel similarly about that
too yeah some people think I can be an
ad optimal resource allocator given my
huge knowledge base and also like
sometimes insane memory of certain
people
and
what do you what do you take of the uh
ethical quandaries that Civilization is
facing with exponential technology and
geopolitics
um
State dependent I do think
um a lot of these are like fundamentally
confused I think people don't exactly
have a clear precise
understanding of what consent means or
what their long-term preferences really
are and I'm not sure if a lot of people
are even capable of formulating these
because it takes massive imagination to
formally thieves especially in the world
that turns out different from one that
you have any imagination you should
perceive whatsoever oh that's good so
it's as though we've had the imagination
kind of sucked out of us due to the
Conformity that's occurring in many ways
but that imagination is so crucial for
us to Envision a world that can have
these ethical quandaries more easily so
yeah for example look what happened to
Indian tribes after the after the
Europeans invaded their lands the
question is are you going to take your
own ways or are you going to adjust to
their ways of course it's more competent
than that because some of them do
encounter legitimate discrimination when
trying to adapt to it white ways but in
general if you're if you want to if you
want to stay robust yourself it's
probably better to acceptable change
happens and make the best out of it and
not hold do I strongly's identity yeah
very interesting Alex
so do you have another
thought that comes to mind that you
think would be important to share in
this conversation that we're having
um
let me think here
I had a lot of thought the other day but
my mind got wiped earlier today
um
yeah I mean I installed my air pollution
meter and holy and I really need to
take the end it has been obsessing over
his air pollution yeah yeah it's
actually it's yellow in here
I bought it three months ago and for
whatever reason I didn't even try to
start using until recently and this is
like a massive failure mode in my part
um there's also just a math film in my
part because you know those air scenes
have 30 day return periods so really
um if you're feeling stuffy or whatever
just get one of those because those are
the scenes that improve quality of life
more than anything else
actually in your lived experience and
your Olympics Alex brings up a very good
point there is that we we we only really
read rarely about these like oh the you
know parts per million of some
particulate in Mumbai or Beijing is
extremely high and uh or in the Bay Area
when we had the fire and then LA and
whatnot yeah there was a high amount of
particulate that we shouldn't be
inhaling and whatnot but in our living
spaces in these homes that the air
quality inside of a home is much
different than outside yeah outside you
have much more fresh air yeah than you
do inside a home and especially if
you're cook if you're baked in the
Heat's all the way on there's people
that are farting sneezing coughing like
on an airplane as well the air quality
on an airplane there's like there's you
know they're quality in a car there's
all these sort of different ways of
measuring the air quality and I'm glad
that you really tie in the importance of
remembering that your lived experience
when you're on a beach and you're in
inhaling fresh from the ocean or from
the sea that air
you can like feel more alive you feel a
lot better and so it's important to to
keep that in mind that's a good point
um I think another
um another thing that that you um you
know that you care a lot about is the
optimization of learning
um and you know we talked about being at
the edge and optimizing your own
learning and other people's learnings
um what would be your recommendation to
young young people and also adults as
well but what is the what is a central
principle that that people can adopt in
order to optimize their learning
um for one thing if you're going to
learn about scenes I I don't think of
yourself as a competitions you learn
calculus at the earliest age possible
but rather
um the the most important thing to learn
first are basically health related
experiential
um memorize the glycemic index the
indexes of all the major Foods
um try to get a pledge a continuous
blood glucose monitor to see how to
respond to certain foods
um
it's like also the live experience get a
lux meter to figure out to
um to measure uh the life spectrum of
your houses do you see um
and also get the faster computer you can
possible
um oftentimes I've learned that for
example getting Amazon Prime it's just
easier it's better to be impulsive on
the themes that um like Amazon Prime
that allow you to be less impulsive on
other scenes
because most people's uh a distance band
was just limited and um you basically
want to
um set things up early on through for
instance and also get reliable
note-taking devices later on so you can
and also use Gmail or you're having
Facebook as much as possible at least
this is what I do because it's those
messages threads are just much easily
searchable then later um aggressively
this archive that is on
um on content you think might get
deleted in five years
um because uh there is a lot of good
stuff online that
isn't that gets deleted and it's a
tragic and then people and then that
causes people to not remember what
scenes were like 10 years ago yeah thank
goodness for the internet way back it's
underperforming yeah but it's so
difficult to Archive everything and ever
that's ever been posted and collected
um but that brings up a good point that
that you mentioned and you mentioned a
bunch of other good ones they're kind of
like increase your day-to-day lived
experience with your health
um okay yeah also I know that learning
reads are much faster we have to say
roommates who you tolerate very well
because they know and you you remember
in the member can build up and really
amazing especially specifically like
remember human human brains or human
brains the biggest human brain human
brain to remember stuff with other
people and their preference is much
better than they can remember say most
abstract thought because let me give you
a context it also allows um someone if
you're tired you also have someone you
rely on that that you can rely on or
whatever
Alex this has been a pleasure yeah yeah
thanks again for coming on to the show
and talking yes yeah this has been I
like our conversation about optimized
learning and the edge of knowledge and
then working on playing the games of
tennis to kind of scrape further past
the edge it's exciting stuff
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below let us
know what you're thinking uh also we
would love for you to build go create
manifest your destiny yeah so nothing
about edginess I would like to mention
is that I think living in places like
Boston San Francisco allow you access to
a huge number of smart highly open
people and in the in the background of
knowing a huge amount of people that if
it's a speed of your learning rate in a
in a really interesting way because I
mean people are better learning facts
with other humans than
um than they are and still certain
things themselves and then you can
basically get estimates rough estimates
of Base um even oftentimes at the scenes
that people say before they're about to
about you partaking the project and this
or the context which then allows you to
form basically estimates of say the
chance of 15 and startup later on or
what exactly they might be missing out
um missing out before starting at a
startup
yep the Alex is this point they're so
crucial you see things as a topology of
competence and influence a lot of the
people at the peaks of those topologies
exist in Metropolis is like Boston and
San Francisco and New York and la and
whatnot so to go and move out to these
areas and go and surround yourself with
these other brilliant leaders and go and
play these games of tennis at the edges
with them it's just going to rock you
forward something yeah the survival
events given
given a dense social environments
especially when you are in them when
you're when you're super young and grow
with them oh gosh yeah getting in there
when you're young 16 18 great ages to
get in
um even earlier is better even at 12.
yeah get in there young you know get in
there young and start tinkering start
tinkering
much love go and build the future
manifest your destiny into the world
everyone we'll see you soon peace okay
bye bye